[Music]
uh Andrew Schultz
on the Kanye West issue now I told Marsh
before the show
that I firmly believe
Andrew Schultz is the next Michael
Rapaport
his whole personality is like it the
whole wigger Vibe he's trying to pull
off the the whole No Cap [ __ ] that
he does he's such a [ __ ] phony
whatever
the newest aging Jewish wigger
look at this hold on hold on nice let's
watch this Phil DeFranco store Style
video for specifically formatted for
Instagram
Kanye West You gopher face Deutsche back
this week Kanye went on a media
Blitzkrieg he threw So Many Stones at
the Jews he's now an honorary General in
the West Bank which is soon to be the
only bank that will accept him that's so
funny that he's not allowed to have a
bank yeah it's so funny that he's being
run off the planet and his point is
being proven oh you [ __ ] stupid
wigger what else what else bud what else
JP Morgan actually canceled his account
so the only transaction Kanye is going
to have is when Caitlyn drops off the
kids
what are you doing Jay Leno stuff what
is it I think he's really trying to do
this is a dead format sir are you doing
a monologue for a for he's doing an
obsolete format you're doing you're
doing top Tech 10 list decks you [ __ ]
douchebag you're doing a monologue for a
podcast
seriously
Jesus [ __ ] Christ coming up guys my
my top 10 uh my top 10 lists uh Kanye
West's top 10 names for new albums get a
[ __ ] grip Bud get a grip
so what exactly did yay say well hungry
hungry Hitler went on drink Champs
it's like that that format of trying to
do a monologue talk fast talk fast talk
Millennial style and then squeeze in as
many references and things
as possible it's it's pretty crazy to
Horn them in there yeah that's what the
most bloated cheeks I've ever seen on a
human and I'm a bloody zigzag
what is that what are you doing you're
[ __ ] are you dipping
you shouldn't be dipping you should be
using Jake's mint shoe Jesus but let me
tell you something he's talking about
he's talking about Kanye and his and his
cheeks you you sound like you just
[ __ ] like you just had your wisdom
teeth removed
you sound like you have a Down syndrome
tongue
the guy looks like a ninja turtle just
had a root canal and proceeded to spout
off more hate than a West Virginia water
fountain he claimed Jordan yeah okay I
get it I understand the water fountain
spit hate out there I think it just
spits out water yeah just because you
look like you're in the Cherry Zionist
daddies doesn't [ __ ] mean anything I
mean I get it I understand but but put
glasses on this guy he'd be [ __ ]
Buddy Holly
I'm sick of you I'm [ __ ] sick of you
you you're you're you're your generic
YouTuber number 456 Andrew okay
I hate this [ __ ] look I think Andrew
Schultz is funny I've said it before and
he can't be funny but what he what do
you what is this Zoomer Tick Tock thing
you're doing man
huh
what are you Philip who funds the bankos
George Floyd was killed by defensive
Philip who funds the bankers yeah is
that who you are
Andrew
wrong Kanye look he's putting emojis
over look at this wrong
how would I know it's wrong you [ __ ]
Doper brother what are you doing
killed by fentanyl wrong Kanye we have
video evidence of a throat getting
crushed and don't worry Kim's not in it
um yeah number one he did die a fentanyl
overdose that is he did his body had
an obscene amount of fentanyl in it and
he had and the knee did is not what
killed him
Andrew
he blamed the Jews for trying to silence
him yay the only Jew that's ever kept
your mouth shut was the dentist that
wired your jaw I hear he blamed juice
for trying to keep him silent and then
they took off his all every single
interview he did off of YouTube and they
silenced him and took his bank account
away and LeBron didn't air his
Barbershop interview with him either
because they silenced him and there were
four Jewish people sitting in the room
with Nora with with the Noriega
interview yeah and there were probably a
bunch of Jewish people sitting in a room
with the original Noriega yeah so that's
a good point he blamed the Jews for
trying to silence him you mean the CIA
hey the only Jew that's ever kept your
mouth shut was the dentist that wired
your jaw oh okay so you're allowed to
make stereotypical comments about Jews
Jews are dentists
because that's what they are I get it I
see Andrew these these these how old is
can you tell me how old Andrew Schultz
please tell me 20. tell me 25. no he's
in his 40s
I hear some people saying Kanye did
bring up some very strong points yes
these points oh Nazis oh we're doing the
Nazi thing again oh [ __ ] Kanye's a Nazi
but you know if Kanye would have said
every exact same things he was saying
but he was saying about [ __ ] white
people Andrew Schultz would have on his
show excitedly within a [ __ ] erection
Because by the way if you don't think
that this wigger doesn't [ __ ] own
Yeezys you're crazy so yeah let me tell
you something right now 100 this guy has
Kanye West clothes every single one of
his albums and if Kanye was saying what
he said and he was saying it about
[ __ ] um saying about white people
he'd be sitting on his little [ __ ]
couch across there well while Kanye was
talking about why people be holding us
down for years and then Schultz will be
like yeah no cap no for real for real no
cap on God or whatever
yeah he um I know he's in his [ __ ]
he's got it's something in his 40s
but it's it is embarrassing and and also
you know you're making 38.
what 38. all right yeah well close
enough but you got dude you [ __ ]
you were in love with Kanye
uh this guy basically engaged in like
cultural blackface his whole life I know
he did the whole wigger thing
you know nobody respects you sir stay in
Elaine do you crowd work videos
[ __ ] seriously yeah why don't you why
don't you why don't you just steal
hofstetter's gimmick where he puts
plants in the audience and uh [ __ ]
takes down hecklers or whatever some
would say Royce he already does that
some would say that I'm not saying that
I am I'm saying that you're a [ __ ]
hack
all right let me tell you if you would
have been around when the actual real
good Comics were around you'd be [ __ ]
Gallagher 3 smashing watermelons all
right [ __ ] out of here Andrew
that's it Kanye isn't the free thinker
he claims to be he just regurgitates the
talk yeah well you're not the black guy
you talk to me
like stop he just returned OverWatch
watch this watch this here we go here we
go he claims to be he just regurgitates
the talking points to the latest
pseudo-intellectual leech around him the
only original thoughts Kanye's ever had
are Amber Kim and Julius by the way that
last sentence that you just said he just
regurgitates as you regurging the
thoughts of of the people around him
that kind of sounds like your buddy Joe
Rogan wouldn't couldn't you argue that
Joe Rogan does the exact same thing
right yeah it's pretty much he's just a
guy that takes he's a chameleon uh what
about Brandon what about Brendan Schaub
huh who steals jokes
we're talking about Brandon okay Brandon
you have to let me finish talking
intellectual leech around yeah original
thoughts Kanye's ever had are Amber Kim
and Julius so is Kanye insane selfishly
I hope he is I'd rather believe this is
the behavior of a guy battling bipolar
disorder then then people noticing what
Jewish people are doing that's for sure
that's for sure yeah I'd rather this guy
to [ __ ] I'd rather just be able to
give this guy a pill and make him stop
noticing things right I don't I don't
want anybody to dig too deep at anything
that dulls your ability to recognize
patterns yeah [ __ ] it seriously go back
to talking back bad about white people
we're fine with that
you could talk about about white people
all you want just do me a favor
all right no more juice stuff
except I've been supporting a Black
Skinhead for decades so my message to
you chipmunk cheeks is simple get better
better friends better therapists better
perspective on the world and better meds
and good luck
because you're gonna need it
did you think that was deeper yeah that
sounded like a threat but it's like a
threat did you think do you think your
that was gonna in his head when he was
practicing in the mirror that he thought
he was going to really cut like he's
gonna go viral with this man people are
going to go wow man after when he was
looking in the mirror and he was putting
Alpha Brain in his hand and throwing it
in his mouth because wrote Joe Rogan
gave him a bunch and he drank his glass
of water he looked in the mirror no
shirt and he flexed a little bit he did
a little Flex he's doing Pilates and
then he said they're gonna [ __ ] love
it and he's read the last part you're
gonna need it pal hey [ __ ] [ __ ]
Jerry Springer was better in fact I'll
bring it at home than you are Jesus
[ __ ] Christ